[Music]
they all say the same thing I'll believe
it when I see it
but that's backwards relief comes first
only then can you see it
I'm asking you to use your imagination
[Music]
we've got one shot at this and I need
the best team my focus right now is my
daughter
tell me and say no I'm gonna say no
what we do is dangerous they're willing
to take that risk I don't know if I am
how does that make you feel putting your
lives at that much risk about your
family all our families know what we
signed up for
you ever think about mom you can't let
her bring us down too
did we make a mistake we've got four
people whose lives depend on my judgment
I can't have you doubting me when I see
it it could be the person that discovers
life on Mars I need you here thattaway
ago
I'll never have the opportunity to do
work this important imagine the
responsibility the astronaut shop the
personal sacrifices that they've enjoyed
I need people who are going to do the
hard thing
and then they strap themselves to a
rocket and they risk their lives enough
already
that's five people
fulfilling the destiny of 8 billion
[Music]
you
you